stand-up comedy is definitely harder I
mean I like being onstage that's always
been you know fun for me better than a
like people ask like I know how do you
go up on stage I don't I don't think I
could ever do it and my answer is like
well I'm having trouble talking to you
right now it's like it's it for some
reason some people just have it in their
genetic makeup that it's easier to go up
and interact with a group of strangers
than it is to have any kind of
meaningful interaction with with it with
a person whose eyes you have to look
into and I'm not saying that I'm a cold
heartless monster but a little sick but
still stand ups harder because it's just
you on your own the great thing about
the onion is it's so collaborative you
know it's you almost kind of take on
this group mind there and people are
really willing to sacrifice their own
personal pet headlines or their own
preference on a joke for the for the
good of the of the the onion for the
good of the product I don't think either
that they that stand-up informs my work
at the onion very much or vice versa
because they're pretty different in
style the stand-up tends to be a little
more of a little more kind of do this
kind of character who that you know
exaggerated Saul of my own nervousness
and neurosis and they tend to be a
little more conceptual like as a eight
minute set then telling a joke and then
telling an unrelated joke and then
telling an unrelated joke I can't I sort
of can't write jokes that way personally
I have to think about how do I want this
this eight minutes to feel so that it
says awkward for the audience as
possible while also being funny and then
sort of right to that as opposed to this
is a good joke that I will expand on and
then find a segue into something else
for me I just can't it's really hard for
me to do that so one thing the onion has
sort of taught me though is how to
actually like
right material and how to hit a joke as
hard as you possibly can relentlessly
until you know it's near to the point of
being too much so having that sense is
something that I've really gotten from
working at the onion you know over four
years but the two are actually pretty
pretty unrelated you know I do have a
website that I keep up as well it's
called the Joe Randazzo Association
which is now that I'm saying it it's
this sort of large heartless corporation
it's the kind of goings-on at the office
you know messages from the from the HR
representative and schedule of events
for a seminar and what the lunch menu is
going to be and it's those kinds of
things so the writing for that has
definitely been influenced a lot by my
time at the onion just in how to how to
really write a joke but it's my own
personal stuff because sometimes you
just need to write your own personal
stuff as well
it's fun but it's also you know horrible
anybody who has to well I don't know if
anybody but when you have to sit down
and write something it's just the most
dreadful feeling in the world for me
anyway you know but it's also really fun
it's just you you forget when you're
having the fun you forget how how
dreadful it is and when you're in the
dreadful your forget how fun it can be
you know and you have to write something
in order to be able to have material to
perform and that's when the fun is so I
guess I sort of actually forced myself
to do it I've listened to other there's
this great podcast I listened to call
discrete creative screenwriting magazine
where Jeff Goldsmith is his name is
senior editor at The Magazine I think
and he interviews different
screenwriters every week and he always
asks them if they what do they do to do
they get writer's block and do they what
do they do to get rid of it and every
time I look at I always have writers but
writer's block is the default position
for me it's like such as struggle to get
these ideas out so they don't want to
come out even though they're in they're
driving me crazy but it's also just an
incredible incredible to be able to have
a career out of making people laugh and
or a job anyway I don't know if it's
going to it'll be a career where you sit
around in a room and make people laugh
and then put together something that's
so great that you know I can be so proud
of you know when you see people on the
street reading the onion it's a really
it's a really wonderful feeling and I
always want to tell them you know I'm
looking the mastheads that's me I worked
there so I'd say it's got to be that the
fun outweighs the the dreadfulness for
sure yeah but it's work you know it's
work